so with the Doctor Strange movie hitting
the theaters this week I wanted to load
up on Doctor Strange related content for
you guys and so in addition to covering
some of his most recent storylines we're
going to make him the focus of our how
to kill superhero series as well now the
reason this presents a challenge is that
as the sorcerer supreme
not only does Doctor Strange possess
immense magical power but because he is
resistant to all diseases and does not
age he is effectively immortal
however this immortality really only
applies to death by natural means and
does not mean that Doctor Strange cannot
be killed by an outside force
accomplishing that however is not an
easy task due to the magical powers of
Doctor Strange that makes him a
formidable foe for almost any opponent
in the Marvel Universe now it's also
important to note here that we're
talking about the current version of
Doctor Strange not the classic version
if you don't know what I'm talking about
Doctor Strange used to be vastly more
powerful than he is now now we'll get
into exactly what it is a he's capable
of as classical Doctor Strange when we
have my video on the powers of Doctor
Strange but suffice it to say during
this time when he was at his most
powerful form he was one of the most
powerful entities in the Marvel
multiverse before he was retconned now
for those of you guys who don't know
retconned
is short for retroactive continuity
where a writer basically changes the
continuity of a character to fit a
desired status quo in the case of Doctor
Strange a he forfeited his title is
sorcerer supreme in New Avengers number
54 in 2009 under the writing of Brian
Michael Bendis with a character known as
brother voodoo taking over the role for
years until they took up the mantle
again in 2013 now although he was
sorcerer supreme again his powers have
never since approached their prereq on
levels now the reason I'm pointing this
out is that I cannot really think of a
way to kill the classic version of
Doctor Strange aside from invoking the
powers of the highest level of cosmic
entities this is important because
during this time he was so powerful that
he could basically remove people from
existence and unlike what we saw with
our Franklin Richards video we can't
simply turn his powers off by
suppressing a mutation so yeah I don't
really know that it could actually be
possible to kill the classic Doctor
Strange and so for that reason we're
going to focus on the modern
version of his character now with that
in mind I really want to run over dr.
Strange's powers just to give you an
idea of what kind of force we're dealing
with here dr. strange draws his power
from various magical entities like the
vishanti and sid Iraq and he's able to
borrow their magical abilities to cast
both offensive and defensive spells in
addition to that he's also aided by the
use of several magical artifacts most
notably the eye of agamotto which is an
amulet that serves to protect its wearer
from the effects of dark magic as well
as the book of Ashanti which contains
immense magical knowledge that dr.
strange can draw from in addition to
this dr. Strange's skills go way beyond
simply caching spells as he's also a
skilled martial artist and is proficient
with various magical weapons and so to
figure out how to kill someone as
powerful as dr. strange the first thing
that we have to diagnose is what its
weaknesses are something to note here is
that as powerful as dr. strange is due
to his magical abilities he's still
human that means that his body while not
susceptible to age or disease is still
limited in durability by the boundaries
of his human physique that being said
he's a character that can theoretically
be killed and pretty much any way that
you can think of to kill a person of
course this is difficult when Doctor
Strange is able to fight off the attack
however there is a long-established
aspect of dr. Strange's powers that
helps us to get around this one of dr.
Strange's abilities is to project
himself into the astral plane which is
basically a plane of existence not mired
to the physical world when he does this
however his astral form separates from
his physical body and he's able to cover
long distances much faster than he ever
could in his physical form the catch
here which has been in continuity ever
since the characters original run in
strange tales is that when dr. strange
enters the astral plane his physical
body enters a catatonic state until
reunited with his astral form this
clearly leaves dr. strange exceptionally
vulnerable to attack so we can
definitely say that the easiest way to
kill dr. strange would be to find his
body during a period of astral
projection and take him out then it's
important to note however that although
dr. Strange's physical body would die
his astral form would continue to exist
on the astral plane indefinitely that
being said that's the easy way and so
let's
soon that were encountering dr. strange
in its physical form alert and prepared
for battle how do we beat him well the
official profile from marvel.com
confirms that dr. strangest powers are
not as effective when his opponent is
one whose powers are derived solely from
science this is something that we've
recently seen during the current Doctor
Strange series by Jason Aaron during the
last days of magic storyline or a group
known as the empirical that worship
science tries to rid the world of magic
altogether now if you want the whole
story on the last days of magic I'll
have that out in the next couple days or
so but suffice it to say this group
poses a significant challenge to Doctor
Strange however we also see that with
enough effort dr. strange is able to use
magic to defeat science-based opponents
and so while dr. strange may be able to
be killed by a science-based opponent
it's not a surefire proposition now
another weakness that can be exploited
is that many of the spells dr. strange
uses require him to use either verbal
incantations or hand gestures to be cast
this may seem insignificant but it
actually presents an opportunity to
incapacitate strange and prevent him
from using his powers thus making him
easier to kill to this end if someone
could simply restrain his hands and take
away his ability to speak in some way
like binding and gagging him he would
pretty much be neutralized entirely of
course this would almost certainly
require someone taking him by surprise
which would undoubtedly prove difficult
due to the clairvoyance afforded to him
by another mystical artifact called the
orb of agamotto and so this is probably
not a very practical way to take care of
dr. strange but at the very least it's
something worth mentioning
now finally because dr. strange is human
and because performing magic takes a
physical toll on a person dr. strange
can be killed by the right opponent
simply by outlasting him this means that
if dr. strange is fighting a character
who can just take an insane amount of
damage like the Hulk dr. Strange's body
will eventually give out from all the
spells he's casting and then he can
easily be defeated by the Hulk or
anybody with his same level of power
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end this is a
tough one killing dr. strange is not an
easy task because he's so powerful but
if you guys have any ideas on how to
kill dr. strange that I haven't listed
here then feel free to post them down in
the comment section because I'm kind of
curious to see what you guys come up
with also if you guys are new here the
comics explained make sure you guys hit
this
button to become part of the Rob core
and Java like if you guys enjoyed this
and I'll catch you all later peace
you
[Music]